Hi everyone.
Welcome to talks at Google.
Today we have Amanda Bradford,
the founder and CEO of dating APP.
The league.
The league is a dating app that combines data and social graphs from both
Facebook and Linkedin to offer privacy from coworkers more context about a
potential match and a curated community of ambitious singles who desire an
equally driven partner.
Amanda have previously worked in technical roles at both salesforce and Google
and holds an Mba from Stanford University and a BS in information systems from
Carnegie Mellon.
It's a great pleasure for us to have Amanda here with us today.
Thanks guys.
[inaudible]
so to get started,
maybe you could tell us a little bit about how you came up with the idea for the
league because it definitely has a unique spin on the dating app.
Yeah,
we definitely,
I took a lot of,
uh,
drew from my own experiences,
I like to say.
So,
um,
I kind of followed your classic design a product that you want to use and don't
really listen to other people and then then kind of figure it out once you,
once you launch it.
So I,
I,
um,
I was at Stanford Business School,
which is obviously a very selective community,
is a pretty intense admissions process.
I think I planned for about two years on like how I was going to get into
Stanford and all the things I needed to do.
And so you could argue like,
you know,
the longer prep time you have to,
the better your application is for,
for business school.
And so I think part of what inspired me around this kind of using,
taking out model and overlaying it onto the dating communities as is a how
effective,
um,
it was in matching people.
I think Peter can talk to this to our class.
I think we had like 20 or 30 couples I just like formed in the first month.
And you're kind of like,
what,
what is it about this community that that kind of creates a way that people can
kind of feel connected faster.
And I think it is because people did put their best effort into their profile.
They worked really hard.
They made sure their,
you know,
their photos are good.
They put their application in and they waited.
And then when they join the community there,
they're there for the right reasons.
And they have the right kind of the right,
you know,
they're going into their class and they're taking notes and it's sort of like
they're good students,
right?
Cause you put all this time into it.
And so I think that's sort of the concept I want to take into dating.
Cause I think dating suffers from people like having a lack of the kind of
intent or motivation to to have like a really core kind of relationship seeking
experience.
Right?
There's a lot of these casual apps.
And so I wanted to kind of turn,
take what I learned at business school and how Stanford does such a good job of
kind of creating this diverse but but you know,
very interconnected community and how to,
can I kind of scale that into the digital?
How can I create like a digital version of a business school?
And so I think that was sort of the like kind of high level vision.
And then of course it gets down into the nuts and bolts of execution,
right,
which is not,
you can't always execute things the right way,
the perfect way on v one.
So I think we're,
we're kind of working towards that but,
but yeah,
so that was I guess the impetus of,
you know me,
I was single,
I was in business school and I was like,
I want this app because I want to save myself time and bad dates and terrible
conversations.
So I was optimizing and kind of for myself,
I guess it selfishly,
and then I was writing,
I found myself writing support feature requests into like hinge and coffee meets
Bagel and tender.
And I was really literally writing them like what I thought they should do.
And then I remember I googled all the founders and I was like looking at their
background.
I'm like,
wait a minute,
I'm more technical than all of these guys.
And I was like,
man,
I like worked at a tech company.
These guys like had come from finance and stuff.
I was like,
why am I writing them feature requests?
Like,
I was like writing specs for them and I was like,
I'm just going to go and build this myself.
So I kind of talked to myself and to like go in and starting this project
instead of kind of complaining about,
you know,
how much dating apps suck all the time.
Which I was.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
So what would you say is the one differentiating feature from the league that
sets it apart from other dating apps out there?
What would you say to someone who's maybe Tinder or bumble?
I mean I always say like our three,
like I always think our three core pillars or value proposition is one.
We just give you much more context about a user.
So we have your linkedin,
we're pulling your linkedin data and your Facebook data and your kind of league
data that you give us.
So you just,
you just know more information about the person,
like step one and then step two because we pull that social graph from work and
uh,
your social life.
So your Facebook friends we actually block you from those I think are awkward
and unnecessary interactions to be like matched with your colleague on a dating
app when you're working on a project with them.
That's just like,
I think unnecessary thing and we don't need to do that anymore because we have
the social graphs at our disposal.
So I think setting up that privacy so people feel like it's a very safe place
that they can be single and they don't have to worry about kind of bleeding into
work.
Um,
and then the last piece is that community aspect.
I think having a community where people are,
you know,
whether or not they are,
that they are self selecting into a community that is for an eagle attarian
relationship.
They are kind of stating somewhat that they're open to like a pretty,
you know,
a power couple relationship or a relationship where both parties are equal.
And so I think creating a community where that is the ethos and the values and
maybe not everyone upholds them all the time,
but if that's kind of part of the table stakes even get in.
So I think that that's sort of how you create a really good value system and
community.
Uh,
like a Google,
you know,
Google has a great,
uh,
internal community.
So I always kind of think he's like,
I want to create where like all the people that use the league,
it feels like a bunch of Googlers,
right?
And they're all debating around how we should kind of,
um,
you know,
dictate the community or what rules we should put in place when governance.
And I want the community to be involved in those decisions.
I don't want to be like a big brother where we're like,
here's what you need to do and you get kicked out if you do this.
I want the,
I want it to be kind of a democracy.
So we're,
we're kind of focusing on like how do we build this social aspect of the
community so that our users can help us with some of these harder decisions
about when do we kicked someone out?
Or when do we let,
is that profile,
you know,
is that league,
where are they and what are we calling league where the,
and as we kind of talk about a lot of these existential questions,
um,
you know,
we want our users to kind of feel involved as if it's their,
their community that they're getting it to have a voice in.
Is the definition of what you consider it to be the worthy,
has that changed over time?
Yeah,
I like that word.
We came up with that word because I think it's like purposefully ambiguous.
Um,
but I think,
you know,
I think what we've seen is,
yeah,
it definitely has changed,
but definitely by region.
So,
you know,
you go from New York where almost half your users are in finance or tech or
media basically.
And then you go to somewhere like we just launched Houston.
Um,
oil and gas is like the number one industry there.
So really understanding,
like we had a whole table of kind of classifications on programs,
um,
schools and like different jobs.
Like,
for instance,
Comcast in Philadelphia is like,
you know the Google,
they're like that's a very,
you know,
so we had to kind of re rank and re calibrate a lot of how we thought about sort
of you know,
selection and,
and what we were using as our proxy.
Cause if you think about it,
where are you just using a bunch of,
we're copying the Google playbook,
which is use GPA as a proxy for intelligence and don't let people,
you know,
I remember when I first started Google,
like half of my friends,
like I don't have a three,
seven,
five GPA so I can't apply.
And you know,
the Google,
his line was always like,
we know that GPA is a stupid,
is a stupid indicator,
but it's a proxy and it's not a bad one.
And I remember we did the case study on that.
I was like that.
I think that's what we do.
That's what we do with kind of education and,
and profession.
It's like we know it's not perfect and there's definitely a lot of other things
and factors to evaluate,
but it's a proxy and it,
it does a pretty good like 80% of the job.
And then I think that's where the kind of fun,
exciting part is where you get the,
the humans involved in,
we can kind of build a perfect solution of next to it.
Yeah.
What are some of the factors that you take into account for determining whether
someone should get approved or not?
Besides GPA?
Well we don't ask GPA but we do,
we have their linkedin profile so you can see,
you know,
what institutions they've attended and you can see what,
what jobs they've held with titles.
They've had their progression of their titles.
You can kind of see,
you get a decent indication of if someone is relatively ambitious from their
linkedin profile.
So I think that that's sort of one thing we look for is just sort of that,
you know,
I kind of think of the league,
it is a little bit of a workaholic community.
Like everyone in it is,
you know,
they're working work is one of their passions and that is a shared value that is
shared across the community.
So I think,
um,
you asked any one of your questions was about like,
you know,
screen based on values,
but I actually would argue that like the people who join the league value
education and they also value ambition and they value people going after in
accomplishing things.
And so I think to me like we've,
we've kind of created one of the few value based dating communities rather than
kind of the,
the Walmarts of the world where they're just sort of,
you know,
people.
So I think we've kind of tried to embed the values into,
into our brand.
And then one of the other things that you mentioned is that your experience in
large tech companies and sort of what made you realize,
hey,
if all these other people who didn't have technical background could do it,
then I can also do it.
So mean,
can you share a little bit about how you drew on your experiences and the skills
you developed while working at salesforce?
And Google to help you when you started your company?
Yeah,
I mean I think the three key skills I learned were sales.
Um,
you know,
starting a company is like,
I would say the first two years it's like 90 sales and then the second two years
I feel like maybe 70% sales.
But it's for the most part you're,
you're moving into a sales role essentially when you start a company.
So I think having a quota,
having learned how to sell,
have you learned how to,
you know,
what it feels like to miss your quota,
what it feels like to,
to,
to do really well and go to club and kind of understand like how kind of,
uh,
the sales mentality works I think is super helpful because when you start,
you're coming,
you're pitching investors are pitching,
employees are pitching,
senior leaders are bridging partners.
So you're always pitching,
you're pitching people to join your app and say this is where you're going to
meet your,
you know,
your significant other.
So I'm,
you know,
I'm pitching users.
So I think that having that sales experience was super helpful.
And I think it allows you to,
to kind of learn how to be confident even if you're not.
So I think when I was at double click I had to sell,
um,
what else?
Google.
But I was selling DoubleClick for publishers,
which if any of you guys know is a very complex product and has a lot of legacy,
there is actually two products happening when I was selling it.
So I was selling x FP and DFP depending on what use case the,
the publisher needed.
And it was a little,
a lot of hand waving.
But I think that helped me learn like that's a very complex system.
So you had to learn it inside and out and then be able to answer all the
questions about it and then also be able to pitch it in a way that,
you know,
made the development team remember your buyer was signed,
the check to actually implement the products.
So I think a Google and you know,
especially at,
especially at Google,
I got very deep into the kind of technical understanding of how the algorithms
work,
the per forecasting.
So I think getting,
getting into the weeds and getting experience,
like really,
I remember reading a Spec at Google that I was like,
this is so over my head because it was about kind of all the like math equations
that go into the actual forecasting of the,
of the ads have if they were gonna run out of ad ad inventory.
So it's a pretty,
you know,
it's very complex system.
But I think getting experience,
getting,
getting super deep and technical,
even if you're not the technical person,
but being able to wrap your head around it because I think that allowed me to
have the product management skills that I could kind of go and design these
really complex systems and manage people implementing them and not kind of get a
get over my head I guess.
So I think learning how to kind of digest large pieces of information and
understand it and be able to explain it back to people.
Well we didn't say what's the hardest part of the process of starting the
company?
Was there anything that maybe was harder than you expected before you went into
it?
Yeah.
Oh,
everything.
Yeah,
everything across the board.
Um,
I think for me,
I waited a long time.
I wanted to really make sure that the zero s like when did you want to start a
company?
I was like,
I was just building an APP,
build an APP that I wanted to use and then I wanted to see if it,
if there was a potential to be a company.
Right.
Did we have a business model where people are going to spend money?
I didn't know that for a while.
Even before we monetize,
we didn't know if we just had like a nice little lifestyle,
you know,
dating app,
which you may,
who knows what's going to happen,
but we didn't know if people are going to spend money.
Right.
So we don't know what,
you kind of don't know the value of your asset until you monetize.
So I think that was something I wish we had done a little bit earlier.
I think I would have taken less diluted of funding and things like that because
we would have realized that our users do want okay pain and do have the,
have the kind of income to pay.
So we,
we sort of kind of delayed our experimentation on monetization a little bit
late.
So I think that that was something that I think would have made it easier
because we would have known that,
okay,
we can expect this amount of money coming in so we don't need to be running as
fast or as stressed out.
But we kind of all thought we were running out of money for like the second
year.
So we were just like,
oh my gosh,
let's,
you know,
working a hundred hour weeks.
So I think,
I think my other takeaway was just hiring a little bit earlier.
Like I waited a very long time because I wanted,
before I recruited amazing people,
like you guys from your amazing jobs at places like Google.
I wanted to make sure that I had a real kind of compelling pitch to,
to,
to convince someone to join my team that,
you know,
we're not going to go under in a year.
We're not going to,
I'm going to be able to pay you market rate,
I'm going to be able to give you.
So I wanted to kind of be able to be in that position to hire really amazing
people.
But because of that,
we're just now kind of getting there.
So for three years I basically was running kind of all the departments pretty,
pretty poorly.
I would say,
you know how to be a B,
B minus level.
So you know,
I was doing marketing,
I'm doing design,
I was doing like the ad creative.
So it was like,
I think that was the hardest part is just like having been kind of a one man
show for for too long.
Yeah.
So out of all those functions that you took on,
which was your favorite,
is there anything that you enjoyed?
Um,
I love,
I realized this,
I'm a,
I love copywriting,
so like my future dream job is that I get to just you like the fun copyrighting
for the league and everybody else can do all the other work.
But,
um,
so yeah,
I think,
I think you learn a lot because you're,
you kind of think of it as a,
you're all over the,
if you think of the company has like a stack,
right?
You're kind of,
you're moving across the stack and you're doing email marketing,
then you're doing Facebook ads,
then you're figuring out how to set up HR and Zendesk and get the support team
to,
you know,
integrated into slack so that people can open a Jira ticket.
So it's like you're doing every job in the company,
right?
So I think you,
in some ways it's awesome because you get to really know what your strengths and
weaknesses are really,
obviously,
cause you're like,
Whoa,
I'm actually really not good at design.
Like that was not a good logo.
So I'm really glad we didn't go with that one,
but I worked on the logo for probably like 40 hours.
And then finally my friend was like,
I'm just taking this off your plate because yours are not good.
So I think like,
but learning that,
right.
And so now I know that I need to,
you know,
have a creative director that I always run stuff by and she has a really good
eye for this.
I think you start to recognize,
especially when you're young and you think you're good at everything and like I,
I kind of learned what I wasn't good at and who I needed to hire.
So I think in some ways it was helpful to kind of do everything because then I
was like these things,
I'm really bad at like not very organized.
So I'm actually not a great product manager.
We just hired a a pm and he's really organized so he's going to compliment my
like more sporadic style of [inaudible] mean I guess.
So I think it's like kind of recognizing your,
your holes and trying to find people to compliment them.
What advice would you give to someone who's currently at a big company who's
maybe interested in starting a company or on the fence about it?
So I was you and I,
what I did is I did this like weekend or weeknight incubator when I was at
Google.
Um,
and my boss was cool.
She let me leave early on like Thursdays.
I think I had to take,
get down there.
It was like one night a week and then I think the team could meet on the
weekend,
but it was a good,
it was a good kind of jumping off point,
like dipping your toe in the water of entrepreneurship because it was like a 12
week program.
The idea was at the end we kind of do a pitch night and you decide if you know
anyone's ideas kind of have legs and people vote on them and then some of the
teams stay together and work on it.
Some don't.
But I think,
you know,
given that you guys are not at a,
uh,
a cloud,
like you're not in graduate school,
like there's a lot of project courses there,
but there are some that will be in San Francisco or mountain view that that can
kind of serve that same purpose.
And I think that was helpful to me because that was my first foray.
I ended up realizing that I was like,
Oh,
I'm actually don't have that many skills to bring to the table cause we were a
group of four and I wasn't the one building the website and then I wasn't,
I was,
I was said I was going to be the designer.
And that was when I first started realizing that wasn't as good at design as as
I thought it was.
Um,
but I think,
I think you learn,
you kind of learned that how to go through the motions of a startup and kind of
what the really annoying and like hard parts are going to be and what the fun
parts are going to be.
And one of the ways that you can grow is as you mentioned by moving into new
markets,
new regions.
So I read recently I think on Forbes that you guys are moving into Houston or
have recently moved into Houston.
So how did you decide that that was the right time to move into that market?
Well,
I mean you brought up a good point is how do you grow without reducing your
selectivity.
One way to do that is to,
to kind of move to different cities,
right?
So you keep New York as,
you know what New York is,
you keep them well and then you go and launch Houston and you're selective in
Houston.
So that's one way to grow that we are working on now.
So we've launched 20 cities this summer.
So that's like one,
one growth channel is just city launches.
Letting our users know where there once they use the APP share at a higher rate.
So honestly opening cities is one of our like key growth strategies.
And then I think the other one will be trying to understand how to kind of,
how to grow virally within a specific community.
So like within Houston we have like a ton of people from Deloitte.
We,
I think we got the whole Houston Deloitte office or something.
So it's like how do we even,
we don't have a ton of other signups in Houston,
right?
So how do we kind of smartly and automatedly you know like go and say,
okay you have a ton of Deloitte people,
how do we maybe create a Deloitte promotion or some sort of leverage,
that kind of core network you have to get the Accenture people.
So I think we're kind of trying to now think a little bit more how do you take
grassroots strategy and kind of automate it into your sort of launch strategy
and your launch marketing.
So that's what we're kind of feeling
cause he know now you have any specific changes in terms of your overall product
vision or maybe some key features that you implemented that change the way
people use the APP now compared to when you first started?
First and foremost,
we'll always be kind of just improving the core product value proposition,
which is we are going to deliver you someone that you know,
we think you'll be compatible with.
But the stuff that I'm really excited about that isn't as revenue generating and
kind of,
but I but we're excited about is we're creating a singles map anonymous.
But this has been like my dream since I just,
we just didn't have the development team to do it when we launched the league
and it was a little bit of a side side feature.
But basically the idea is like,
let's say your friend is recently out of relationship and it's Friday night and
it's her,
you know,
you want to take her out,
rebound,
go out and like,
you know,
drink and meet some nice single people.
So you're like,
where do you go in San Francisco for?
That's a very hard question and you're like,
there's nowhere to go,
right?
Where are the single people?
So basically,
um,
what we want to do is get,
is allow people to kind of refresh the map and then see where,
you know,
if all the single people are at,
what is the one in mountain view of the big bar.
You guys always go to Google bar sports.
Yeah.
Everyone's at sports page wasn't.
Um,
then you could see that on the map and be like maybe to their sports pages.
A Good Friday night spot.
So I don't know.
We'll see.
We'll see how it,
how it goes.
We're kind of MVP and it right now.
But I think,
I think the idea is like how do we,
I want to increase the efficiency.
I'm just like the whole problem,
which is a single people don't know other people are single.
Right?
So that's sort of why I love the slap bracelets.
So you always do,
cause it's like when you were a glow in the dark slap bracelet,
you are single.
So lets you know you're not going to have any of the kind of accidental,
you're hitting on someone who has a boyfriend or a girlfriend or something like
that.
So I just like,
I,
I've personally want to like add more clarity and transparency and efficiency to
the process and I think our users are smart enough to kind of figure a lot of
stuff out.
It's just like we're trying to remove the kind of the noise and the clutter and
help them kind of get to the end goal faster.
Which is meeting someone offline that you,
you know,
you fancy I guess.
Yeah.
The map feature sort of reminds me of the new snapchat.
I know.
Well I mean I'd actually,
I'm not a snapchat user cause I'm too old.
I decided I was like Instagram,
I'm stopping at Instagram.
Um,
but I just looked at the snapchat feature is very similar.
We want to keep ours like anonymous of course.
So you're not like,
that's really creepy to to be like that match didn't like me back.
But he's over here.
You don't want,
you don't want people to like go tab too much information.
But I think just getting a,
getting a high level understanding of like where you're kind of nightlife is
going on in your city.
And then I think then we,
to me,
this helps us move into more of a social networking like vibe and aspect.
And then if you can have people who aren't single and single,
just using the APP as like kind of a nightlife radar app,
then I think it becomes a lot more interesting and we can start to think about
can we actually become a social network or are we always going to be a,
you know,
a dating service.
Yeah.
So I think in San Francisco's case there's single people out there,
but a really hard part of the process is that everyone's so busy that all have
soul cycle man schedules to meet up.
Yeah.
You can do to make the process of actually meeting all.
Exactly.
And that's why we invested a lot in events.
So we have actually another feature that we're coming out with is like a fully
aggregated events feed.
So right now we just kind of handpicked cool events in our cities that we think
are on brand and cool.
But instead I think as we think about kind of moving into more of a utility and
trying to be a,
you know,
a social network that people actually depend on in use,
on a weekly basis,
then we want to start getting into understanding kind of where the user is,
why they're opening the APP at that time.
Right.
And what,
what their kind of their use case is at that moment.
So we don't want to get into like the Tinder,
like I'm looking for tonight,
where do I go tonight thing.
But I think of it as more of like events.
Like if I can meet three of my matches by going to the tipsy pig on Friday night
and I don't have to have a one and a half like awkward Starbucks,
like interview meeting with three people,
um,
do you know,
during my work day,
to me that's way more efficient.
I got to kind of meet them in a more fun environment.
Maybe I hit it off with some of them,
maybe I didn't.
I got to talk to them for five or 10 minutes maybe.
I like all three of them,
but I think to me like kind of moving group,
like what group we're used to do,
which was a competitor that died,
but they set up three people in three,
three guys and three girls.
Um,
and people actually really liked that.
Like I remember when I was doing user research,
like people liked the concept.
There wasn't a lot of retention.
Is that a retention problem?
No one did like a second group are,
but there is something there I think with like taking away the kind of not
requiring everyone to go to these one on one on one kind of interview style
dates and if we can kind of change the format of dating and make it more group
and fun and oriented around values or hobbies or yoga or people with dogs or you
know,
whatever it might be,
I think that,
I think to me,
I think that's like a much more efficient way to date and to meet new people.
What would you say is one feature that the league offers?
A lot of people don't know about that maybe you wished they knew?
Well,
I guess I would say a lot of people know about this,
but Google is hate this feature.
So cause it basically blocks you from all your Googlers.
We use linkedin well can basically,
it's like Google and Facebook has,
but then everyone else is like thank you for not matching me with my coworker
next to in the cube next to me.
But yeah,
that I would say that feature is probably pretty hidden is just that when you
do,
because we ask you to log in with your Linkedin,
which people think is kind of weird.
It actually allows us to then unblock you from anyone who works with you or
anyone you're connected to.
So I was in sales so I was always friending people on linkedin and I did a lot
of like business development on linkedin.
So like the last thing I wanted to do was see like one of the people I was kind
of doing business deals with on my feed.
Like that's weird.
So I was like,
let's just prevent that situation.
So I talked about that a little bit,
but that one is hard to that one.
Not everyone knows about.
And then I would say you can also sort,
so I had come from the CRM industry,
right?
So when I look at the match screen of the League,
um,
everyone's like,
it's very,
you know,
there's so much data there.
And I'm like,
well if you're like as a CRM person,
like that's,
you want to see all of the information kind of condensed and like an executive
summary.
So if you look at our match screen,
um,
I'm like the only one on the team that likes that screen,
but I like it because it shows you all the information you need and you can
actually sort your matches by least flaky,
most popular,
most recent,
and then,
uh,
your best match.
And a lot of people don't know that,
but we use the best match algorithm is actually pretty good and no one uses that
either.
So those are the,
those are the under,
under marketed,
I would call them under marketed features in the APP because we haven't done
much to kind of tell the users about them.
In terms of the elite sort of brand that yeah,
the,
the League has,
do you think that that could potentially also lead to maybe like inadequate
matches?
Because I think that a lot of times people might find that they're really
compatible with someone who doesn't necessarily come from the same like high
level social class background that they do there.
There's cross social class relationships.
Well statistically that's not true.
I mean if you just look like if we're designing like I always like to say
everything's a proxy and your v one is never going to be perfect,
right?
So you have to just ignore some of the outline.
You use cases,
it's like product management,
right?
So that's sort of the way that sort of,
the way I think about is I looked at like statistically who is getting married
to each other,
right?
So similar age,
similar education level and actually similar industry is highly significant.
So,
I mean,
you,
I guess you can either try to like go with the data or go against the data,
right?
But I think for,
for us,
if it's already happening in the real world,
like we're just trying to create a software platform that facilitates that.
We're not trying to sort of,
I mean,
eventually I've,
yeah,
maybe I do want to change what people are doing in the real world.
I think that's when you start to have influence.
When you're a company like Google,
you can actually start to,
to really make a change in society and how people are,
are using and using software.
But I think at our stage we just want to be able to get to that point and
getting,
give our users what they need,
um,
what they're kind of coming to our door for.
So,
I don't know,
I guess I look at it as we're,
we're kind of using math and data to give you kind of the best probability of
someone you would match with.
And we're not kind of trying to change the data set that we're using.
We're trying to use the data set that people have researched for 20 or 30 years
and apply it in like a smarter way.
So,
um,
eventually I want to have my own research team and,
and kind of maybe,
you know,
debunked some of this stuff or you know,
come up with find out how to,
you know,
I think we always talk about that.
We want to,
you know,
the creatives that never meet the finance people.
How do we,
how do we make sure that they're both kind of coming into the community on equal
amounts?
Um,
and,
and it's a challenge.
Like we have way more finance people coming in to New York community,
then,
you know,
creatives are people on Broadway and that's just,
that's,
I think that's just a fact of like New York population,
but the like a little bit of a fact of life and it is going to be harder for,
you know,
that match to happen in the real world too.
So it shouldn't it be kind of harder for it to happen on a dating APP.
So we tried to think that we're kind of mimicking the real world and making it
more efficient and useful and not trying to,
to kind of tell people what,
you know,
what they should or shouldn't be doing at this point.
But we do kick people out if they're bad.
So we do,
we do,
we do tell people not,
we do make sure people are respectful.
Um,
so that's one thing we're pretty hard and hard and fast on.
But as far as like what,
you know,
whether they're swiping or being super picky,
I mean we give them advice,
but if people want to be picky and say no to every single person,
we give them for a whole year and then complain and you can't please everybody.
As you guys know,
product managers,
it's like the,
you always have that email that keeps you up at night.
And from like we just had from a,
it was actually a 72 year old lesbian woman who was very mad.
I mean,
because we didn't have anyone to give her and you know,
we refunded her,
but I,
I stay,
you know,
I like legit research.
And I was like,
what if we did,
I'm an advertising campaign to get.
And then I was like,
this is not at the end of the day,
especially if you're running a company,
you gotta,
you gotta cut that 20% off.
I cannot be worrying about the 72 year old lesbian right now when we don't,
we have 30 year olds maybe running out of matches that's way higher,
you know,
more critical of a problem.
So it's all kind of triage and I think a lot of the questions that go into like
things we want to do when we,
when we have more people on staff are yes,
like educating people on why you should be open minded and why you shouldn't
reject people in their five,
nine instead of five,
10.
And you don't have a lot of,
I have a lot of like blog posts saved up in me that I want to help people kind
of to,
to optimize their dating life.
But first we got to kind of get the product out
in terms of growth.
Uh,
another one of the opportunities can be expanding more into,
uh,
the LGBT community.
So have you thought about ways to do that?
Right.
How we do,
we have a very good,
we have a great LGBT community in New York and actually a really good one in
London.
Like it's like weirdly a disproportionate.
Um,
but we haven't done any targeted marketing that's been all word of mouth
through,
through that.
Um,
cause actually on Facebook you can't,
you can only target straight people are like they make you have a,
they make you change,
have a separate campaign for each one.
So we,
it's that,
that's been a pretty,
pretty viral community for us.
So we,
yeah,
we want to,
I think as we think about like where to spend in marketing,
it's definitely getting investing in LGBT I think cause I,
they also spent a lot too,
so it's like the,
I would say are,
are LGBT and the New York finance,
they both are kind of one of our better,
better customers.
So we definitely want to learn how to kind of mark it to them and acquire them
more.
Scalably
I want to go back a little bit to the filtering by education level and job.
Cause something that I was thinking about was that you're using this as a proxy
for determining whether someone is driven right in some ways,
uh,
but there's cases where people could be driven and really passionate about
something but don't necessarily have the education level.
It doesn't come out.
So like potentially like it could be an artist and you're really passionate
about that are great artists.
But in terms of education and job that might not be shown in your resume or you
might all have a linkedin page.
So have you thought about other things that you can use as proxies to get at
that sentiment?
Yeah,
we talked a lot about that because linkedin is going to be calm right now.
Linkedin is fine and it's sort of serving as a natural curation mechanism for
us.
Cause if you don't have a linkedin account,
like you know,
you drop off at that point,
right?
So we almost don't even have to deal with the people that don't have,
have linkedin accounts.
But a lot of those are creatives.
And so we have net,
when we launched la,
we had a big problem because a lot of people in la don't use linkedin.
It's like kind of not cool if like you're a cool person in the industry,
you're not on linkedin really.
So we ended up building a new flow so you could pay to skip it.
Then for an a la La when we launched into the kind of comping a lot of people to
get through that kind of original linkedin screen.
And I think as we think about international,
that's going to be a huge issue for us too because not everyone internationally
is kind of as linkedin focus.
It's very white collar,
right?
So as you get into,
as you get into kind of the creative that producers,
they're not on,
there might be on our CMDB,
they're on,
so we talked about Amex like has all the API login.
So we're,
we're kind of brainstorming with some different ways to,
to kind of get start to get outside of our core linkedin,
like white collar demographic.
But I would say that linkedin does have a pretty big audience.
So I think for,
you know,
short term,
we want to at least just get at least the linkedin users in those cities that
were live.
And then like step two is let's get people that don't have linkedin accounts and
figure out how to get them in.
I think there's a lot of professional networks that are sort of more targeted.
I think there's also one Doximity for Dr,
so we've talked to them.
Um,
that's probably one will do next year.
Doximity.
Hi.
If you can talk about how you think about user retention,
because it seems like if people are really successful,
then they may just turn off the platform very quickly.
Yeah.
And then on the other hand,
if they really hate the experience,
they'll turn off quickly,
but there's like the sweet spot of people for maybe like a little bit frustrated
somehow,
but like enjoy the platform and we'll like it for a long time and spend money.
So like how do you,
when people churn
good turn of turn.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
so we,
we have,
we call it good turn and Badger and we keep our names pretty simple here.
But,
um,
yeah.
And uh,
we are,
we are excited about good Sharon.
I think,
I think that worrying about good Sharon is like worrying about someone stealing
your idea when you're an entrepreneur.
It's kind of like that,
that means your product is doing the job that it was designed.
Did you,
and Oh you,
hopefully you can kind of be smart enough to build a business model around that
to support that job that it's doing.
So we don't worry about vid churn.
Um,
and I like to think that every good churn is like five new users in my head.
I think of that because if they tell their friends or they tie it at the
marriage ceremony or you know,
by the,
just how viral dating is in general,
people tend to say where they met.
So I like,
I'm super,
if everybody did good churn right away,
we'd be like,
that'd be an amazing problem to have.
Um,
bad churn is not good and bad churn typically happens when people don't get
matches.
So they usually,
and that is related to either pickiness or they're saying no to everyone there.
I really just not happy with the selection or they're very low,
low performing,
and everyone says no to them.
Right.
So that's sort of the like two use cases or they're kind of been,
there's a bunch of people in the middle of that kind of Sorta picky.
Not really,
but also not really happy,
not getting a ton of mattress.
Do you have kind of the,
so yeah,
there's a lot of different kinds of experiences people can have on the APP and I
think that's one of the hardest parts of the product management for it is that
you kind of have,
I mean we don't really,
we're just now we're doing kind of cohorts and segments,
but you like the older people do churn faster,
right?
So it's like everybody,
it's almost like you have so many different customers segments to to model that
it gets a little bit confusing.
So what we've started to do is now just focus on our target,
our sweet spot,
like all our,
our revenue,
our user growth,
that referrals are all like 25 36 is sort of our sweet spot.
So really focusing on on in that cohort,
are we getting bad churn and we don't want bad turn in that cohort.
But if in the other cohorts were kind of okay because they're a little bit
outside of our sweet spot.
So it's going to just being like super focused on and if the bad and it's the
people turned out why they did and you can kind of see,
you can sort of,
the cool thing about the,
just having all the data is you can literally see someone's exact experience who
they saw if they liked them,
maybe they saw a terrible profile and like disabled their account.
You can actually go and see that.
So you can kind of track back what caused users to churn.
And,
and usually it is,
uh,
it usually is like a lack of,
for us it's a lack of matches,
which means that's why we were so focused on improving the algorithm because
that's going to increase retention a ton.
If you get one good match a week,
you're going to stay on,
even if it's only one.
But if we're not giving you one for three weeks,
you're going to churn.
So for us that's optimizing the algorithm better to to make sure you're not
getting,
you're here getting good,
you're getting good matches and we're not getting them all at once at the
beginning and burn through them.
So that's sort of the other game theory part is that I think gets into ethics a
little bit is like do you give everyone their best matches right at the
beginning or do you sprinkle in different,
you know,
offering so that you are always are liking the the guy we think you should.
Like when you only have,
you know,
a hundred or a couple thousand people signed up in a city,
who do you let in?
Um,
right now we've started moving into an entirely like predictive model based um,
selection.
Where rather than us being like,
Oh,
you're a look like a good,
you'd be good for the brand,
you integrated school,
you have a great profile.
Like let's put you in instead.
We actually look and see did their preferences overlap with other people and are
they going to have that good time inside?
Because if the girl only like 60 year old men and we don't have any six year old
men and she's not going to have a good time at the party.
So obviously so.
So it's,
it's interesting cause you can start to kind of almost launched with people that
you are predicting are to find a match.
So now we're almost predicting matches like weeks in advance of when we launched
the cities and we're only launching with people we think are going to get a
match.
So yeah,
it's,
it's a totally different strategy than kind of before when it was very guesswork
and like oh these are people that we think we're going to match.
But it was very human and now it's completely data driven based on you know,
their pickiness well if it's a brand new user,
it's based on just users that resemble them and what they've,
they've seen in the past and we can kind of predict what the behavior is going
to be once we launched this year.
The city.
Um,
I have a question about how you choose what's a good education.
So activity if it's level or a school,
cause I feel like I know in 2013 actually Laszlo came out and said that GPA was
totally agnostic to Googlers success.
Yeah.
So it actually wasn't indicative of anything.
The only thing he said that wasn't the New York Times is conversation and
interviewing.
And so given that a lot of schools,
um,
you know,
you can make arguments that some schools are better than others,
but also there's a lot of industry specific knowledge.
It comes from particular schools.
So we value,
we've valued profession like just as high as education.
So is the education like what school you go to or what level of education
program base,
like what metric do like a medical school.
So if went to any medical school in the United States,
that's considered a highly selective in our,
like in our tiering system.
So like for the particular undergraduate,
like Oh this is an ivy league school versus this is,
so for all,
we have three categories we call a school.
Highly selective,
selective,
or it's just not tagged.
So you mark every school and programs.
So like for instance,
if you're,
like you said,
a doctor,
if you're,
uh,
in a doctor's program at University of Alabama,
that is highly selective.
You're studying to be a doctor,
right?
So it's,
it's,
it's program based.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that was my question was like what type of Algorithmic,
like how do you approach that algorithmically or using,
well,
we haven't done anything super cool yet,
but right now it's sort of in like v two stage where we're kind of a,
we've label,
we have,
we've sort of had the data sent tagged,
but he's not very international right now.
So we're kind of adding in more international programs.
And now that we're,
we're in London and Toronto,
so we,
we learned a lot of like,
oh,
we didn't have this school in our database.
So now we're kind of crowd sourcing a bunch of the schools and the programs and
everyone writes him a little bit different on linkedin.
So it's not perfect.
But if we see like we can look for the word,
you know,
MD or something to show that they are kind of investing in higher education and
that sort of the,
the way we're trying to kind of proxy it,
and I like to think of the education is it's less of a,
I think people use it as,
as a proxy for like,
I wouldn't say ambition,
I guess it would say the way,
the way that people I've seen use it,
like I've actually watched different people use the filters and it is,
it is definitely for people with graduate degrees.
He's like the only people that care about it are the ones that graduate degrees.
And I think it is because they tend to want to find someone that shares their
values and that is in there kind of industry.
Right.
So we've noticed that I looked at,
we did an analysis on who actually uses the education filter and it's usually
people in their thirties and with a graduate degree,
doctor,
lawyer,
something like that.
So,
but yeah,
it's interesting to see how like,
who uses these and who doesn't.
And it's,
it's pretty,
uh,
it's pretty interesting.
We should write a book sometime but,
but the good news is though,
if anyone's read data Clemson,
which was kind of the last big book written about online dating,
um,
we want to kind of do an update to that by the good news is a lot of the kind of
like terrible trends he talks about,
which you know is still true across the board in dating.
But it they are going,
they are getting better.
Like people are getting more open minded,
people are getting and was raised is done online dating.
People are getting less hightest,
less elitist.
Like we've noticed it in our,
our data even in the past three years like people are becoming more open minded
on online dating and it just,
it's a shift that takes time.
So I think as much as we can like be mad about it and hate the space,
I think it is improving these products using more authentication,
getting more information about these are,
I think it is helping us as a society kind of make better matches for ourselves.
So I would,
I would disagree with the point that like it's causing people to be,
you know,
more elitist.
I actually think it's because you're able to see all these people that you
weren't able to see before and your homogeneous,
you know,
Google,
Google life or whatever you were at in my life with San Bernardino,
I took one bus back and forth.
So it's like I didn't get out of my comfort zone.
So I like to think that,
I mean in a study just came out actually that online dating is,
is actually widening people's,
um,
like you know,
preferences.
And also there's a lot more interracial marriages happening just because of the
surge of online dating,
which they're attributing it 100% to online dating.
So that just came out in,
I'll send you guys to,
to follow up.
But that just came out in I think the New York Times or something about,
about how online dating is resulting in kind of a more,
uh,
open minded society.
I'll do an question from the dory from someone who's watching in the livestream.
You keep using the term singles,
but open relationships and polyamory are becoming more and more prevalent
nowadays.
This,
the league explicitly tried to avoid such users.
It doesn't seem to discriminate against singles and open relationships,
but does have a bias against openly married?
What's your take?
Yeah,
it's a good,
it's a good question.
Um,
I think when we launched we want it to be really clear about what the product
was and what the brand was,
what the,
what the offering was.
So it was for people looking for long,
long or serious relationships,
soul mates,
life partners.
Um,
it wasn't for casual sex and it wasn't for a person in an open relationship
trying to find another person to add to their people.
So,
I mean,
it was,
if that was,
it was a very kind of like core focused use case.
Like I said,
I was designing it for myself,
to me that that wasn't gonna help me solve my problem more.
So I designed it to be,
you know,
to speak very clearly about why you should be there.
I think we've,
we've kicked out,
we kicked out a couple of people that were married and using it for open
relationships.
And I think I,
I think that's,
it's the way I think about it is there's a ton of dating apps out there and they
are all,
it's getting more and more like niche and fragmented and use case specific.
So I mean I think I can even name some that are like designed for three ways are
designed for polyamory.
So I think,
I think that,
um,
instead of trying to be everything to everyone,
why don't we just get really good at,
at the,
the demographic we have and uh,
assume that someone else will kind of take that opportunity.
I guess one thing I've learned the last three years,
it's like you can't go after every opportunity.
I know you're going to,
you're going to burn out.
And we have,
so it's like you have to,
you have to make hard,
hard decisions.
And I think for us it's like I can't worry about the over 40 year olds and I
can't worry about the,
you know,
you can't worry about the,
the polyamorous and the open relationship people because they're not
contributing meaningfully to like actually our,
you know,
our core business that we're building our core company that we're building.
Right.
So it's like you have to support the users that are funding you and then let's
build them a product and then if we can kind of get that right,
then there's a lot more products and people to build for.
So I kind of think of that as like when we have an r and d department.
Sure.
Okay.
Oh,
I have a question.
Um,
how do you get started?
Like,
um,
you got you,
I heard you say you got four people and how they do get three other people on
board with you.
Yeah.
It looks like Linkedin is kind of critical to,
to y'all two days.
Uh,
how did you get partnership with them and were you like worried if they like,
is it open API or something?
Like you see it going?
Who is draw that at some point?
Yes,
that's a good question.
Um,
the linkedin thing is interesting now that they're bought by Microsoft
especially,
but um,
we were there,
we were like the first one to use them and they were like,
wait,
a dating site wants to use us.
I was like,
you guys have the best day to say in the world.
Of course I want to use it.
So we kind of got grandfathered in because we,
because people are actually creating linkedin accounts to join our APP,
which is like really high friction versus when you're paying for a user,
you're like,
what?
So we,
but we were giving them like users in an in a sense because people are like,
oh,
I need a linkedin account.
I don't want to pay,
so I'll go create a linkedin account and then authenticate.
So,
so I think they saw that there's clear like benefit in new users.
So it's sort of,
we kind of positioned it that way.
It's like we'll be,
we'll be giving you new leads and we're not going to do anything spammy or
anything weird.
We're just literally using,
displaying the data.
So,
so they,
they actually have cut off their API access now the public profile view.
So we actually are grandfathered into like a pretty nice little moat I guess we
have from ABF some extra API permissions.
Um,
your other question was about sort of starting start.
How so?
Yeah,
so the starting was funny.
This is why now we're doing these small cities.
I'm having like flashbacks to when I was in San Francisco and literally going
door to door and knocking and be like,
do you know any single people?
Can you text them right now?
And I need like 200 more people so we can launch.
So what I did is I set myself a goal of like 300 guys and 300 girls and we
actually built it into the waitlist screen.
I'm like a little progress bar of like how many more women and men were needed
to get to like the 300.
And so,
um,
which was kind of overkill.
I guess I'm a feature because it was only pertinent for,
you know,
from zero to 300 and then it was sort of outdated at that point.
But it took a long time to get to zero to 300 in each gender category.
So,
um,
but yeah,
that was sort of the goal is once we got to 300,
we are going to launch and see if it worked.
And it's obviously very small number of users.
So that was also why there's only three to five potentials given every day.
Cause I was like well how do we launch this?
And we,
you know,
with,
cause it was in the era of like unlimited swipes and tenure was giving everybody
as many as you wanted.
So um,
we actually kind of stole,
not stole I guess pulled a page out of the coffee meets Bagel and hinges book
cause they were doing the kind of daily batch thing.
And I was like,
well let's do that and make it more fun,
like happy hour.
And then,
um,
and so that's why we give only three to five a day so that we don't have to be
concerned about supply issues,
especially upon launch.
Right.
Because some of the people were launching and they only have,
I think we only have like a hundred people ready to show them.
And then we are kind of betting that we'll be acquiring more people and they'll
be coming in.
And so you'd have to,
you have to kind of figure out how much of a archive or I guess backlog you have
to kind of create first before you launch.
So you know how many you need.
So we found that it's about 300 guys and 300 girls is sort of the minimum you
need,
cause you have to assume that like 70 70% might log in.
Right.
And then of the ones that log in,
they might not some guy be picky.
So you kind of want to make sure that have enough people that actually had a
good experience at the end of that kind of first launch experience.
Okay.
Uh,
so the first question kind of piggybacks off of what you just mentioned and the
other one is completely different.
Um,
so how did you guys originally get to that number?
300?
It's kind of random I guess.
Um,
yeah,
I think we a couple of different ways.
You're kind of triangulated it.
So one was that was just the number I picked for launching San Francisco.
So that was me being very,
I guess,
uh,
you know,
cursory.
And then the second piece was we now looked,
we did this model that predicts how many happy people are going to be in a
cohort on a wait list.
So we can see in Indianapolis there's 438 people of the like 2000 that we
predict will like have a good time in the party.
So that's sort of the,
it's a little bit of how many people do you need to make sure there's going to
be a good amount of happy users.
So that's sort of where that 300 comes from.
Cause if we've,
we've found that if there's at least 400 is about the right happy users.
So then you add that you assume not all of them log in and stuff,
so you get to kind of about 300,
300.
Okay,
cool.
Uh,
and question two is you mentioned that you did a incubator through the nights.
Yeah.
Because after you're working here,
yeah,
it was like Google.
Um,
how's the SF office though?
So it's easier to commute to it,
but it was at,
um,
it was women 2.0 put it on.
But it was for men and women.
Um,
it was just called,
I have now,
I can't remember,
I just call it like a,
I don't know,
innovation program or something,
but,
but yeah,
it was cool just cause it was,
it got you in the emotion but you weren't,
you know,
it wasn't your day job.
Everyone had a day job,
so it was a little bit less intense and you got to kind of,
yeah,
try your hand at it without having a ton of pressure.
Okay.
Cause that was the other question is how did you manage like doing that and
working here?
Oh yeah.
Well,
I didn't really,
I,
I know I worked,
I worked hard at Google,
so I did,
I just worked a lot.
Like that was why when I was one of the reasons why I have relationship issues
because I was working so hard.
So,
um,
so it all comes back,
right?
It all comes back full circle.
Um,
but yeah,
I think,
I think I just tried to balance it.
I,
I did a lot of that on the weekends.
They'd would be like,
almost my whole weekend would be on that.
And then at nights I would work till seven and then like work on it from seven
to nine in like a conference room here and like just to hammer it out.
So that's how I did the g match study for the gym out here too.
But yeah,
maybe we have time for one more question.
Lucky purple back there.
Uh,
on business school.
two things.
One,
a business school that was useful for starting a startup after two years at
Google.
Did you feel like you needed to go to business school to leave and sort of
startup?
Yeah,
it's a really good question.
Um,
I think if you know,
you want to start a startup and you get into a top three business school,
you should go because it's just,
it's going to help the process of starting up.
It's just gonna it's,
it's worth the money.
I guess if you think about it,
just like as a pure Roi based argument and like the amount of amazing people you
can get mentored by the amount of like access to funding environment like you,
you just,
you,
you paying opportunity,
right?
You're paying for opportunity to,
to kind of be presented to you.
So I think,
I think if,
if that's it,
but I don't think,
I think once you get out of the,
like top one or two or three programs,
I then I think it becomes a lot about what are you going to learn that is going
to change the trajectory of your career,
right?
Because I think,
um,
and you don't know if you want to be,
I guess a lot of our funding came from connections I made at Stanford.
So that's why I,
I can't,
with a straight face say you didn't need to go.
I didn't need to go,
but like did I use anything I learned from business school?
I feel like I knew what I didn't know.
Like I knew enough about the,
cause we've studied entrepreneurship for like two years.
So you know enough of,
you've heard enough horror stories and terrible stories.
You kind of know that you need to hire someone or you know,
you should be doing this as a model or you know,
you should be doing more data analysis there so you kind of know your blind
spots a little bit.
So I think you can kind of,
you run your company better because you have that knowledge.
But I don't think it's like a huge,
I don't think it's a huge,
besides that,
like access to funding and obviously the network that helps,
helped us launch,
launch the league,
the League specifically because there's a lot of Stanford people on it.
But yeah,
I dunno,
I guess I would say if you know,
you want to start a company and you yeah,
you get into a place like Stanford,
like there they are born and bred to like,
you know,
put entrepreneurs out into the world.
So they're very good at,
they're very good at that.
And I felt very confident coming out and starting a company and I think that's
like hard to value,
like that confidence and the ability to,
especially as a single founder,
no opponent,
double entendre.
I know,
but uh,
especially as a single founder,
I think having that like degree,
even though it's a little like,
I don't like credential.
Like I think I don't care that much about pedigree,
but I do think it helps you just kind of walk into a room and be like,
yes,
I'm fundraising.
Yes,
I'm doing this,
you know,
and having people take you seriously.
So I do.
I do think there's something there that you have to give credit for.
But yeah,
I'm not like super bowl.
I mean,
it's expensive.
It's an expensive project,
business school.
So I had a lot of sleepless nights about it before I went.
It's time's up.
So thank you everyone for coming and thank you,
Amanda.
Yeah,
so fun.
Great question.